Nick a eu une excellente idée pour une
entreprise lucrative appelée Wild Times
où les prédateurs pourraient en fait enlever
leur collier et se comporter comme des
prédateurs et chasser des choses et continuer sur
cette chose appelée Aurora Koechner qui
est comme des montagnes russes qui leur permettent de faire la
guerre et  être eux-mêmes et donc c'était une
entreprise parfaite pour gagner de l'argent pour Nick,
mais il n'avait rien de tout cela aucun des
NS non non dinero y Capital no dinero de
néanmoins ou quatre et il a un pauvre gars qui a
besoin de gagner de l'argent et il a dû aller
à  toutes ces banques tu sais elles disent tu
ne peux pas mettre un prix sur le bonheur et moi je dis
tu peux taper là c'est 1995 un billet
j'ai un immeuble aligné j'ai les
plans j'ai le staff j'ai un rêve
la seule chose que je fais  Je n'ai pas de prêt
pour y arriver ami m'aideras-tu à
y arriver m'aideras-tu à y
arriver m'aideras-tu à y arriver
Je vais juste le mettre sur la table
tu n'aimes pas les mammifères comme  moi et je
n'aime pas les mammifères comme toi mais qu'est-ce que
c'est  e tous les deux comme nous aimons tous les deux l'argent tu l'
as je veux l'emprunter et ensuite nous en
ferons beaucoup tous les deux hmm désespéré hein
je suis désespéré je suis désespéré regarde
je comprends personne ne veut jeter de l'argent sur
un rat  trou achèterait que je voulais dire sans
manquer de respect ils disent que vous ne pouvez pas mettre un
prix sur le bonheur je dis de la foutaise quoi
bien ce n'était pas malheureux maintenant
je ne veux pas battre un cheval mort